- Après des demandes répétées
durant des décennies, ça aura
pris la découverte de restes
humains sur les terrainsd'ancies
pour que le pape décide de venir
s'excuser auprès des nations
autochtones.
Quelques semaines après avoir
reçu la visite d'une délégation
de chefs de plusieurs nations
au Vatican, l'itinéraire
du souverain pontifesemble se p.
Sa sainteté doit déjà se rendre
au Congo et au Soudan
en juillet. Il pourrait ensuite
visiter Québec, Iqaluit
et Edmonton.
Mgr GÉRALD CYPRIEN-LACROIX,
archevêque de Québec
- Il souhaitait, si les chos
s'adonnent, de venir autour
de la fête de Sainte-Anne. Ah!
Ça, ça nous situe dans le temps.
La fête de Sainte-Anne,
c'est le 26 juillet. Alors
viendra-t-il pour la fête,
un peu avant la fête ou après
la fête? Mais ça nous donne déjà
une idée.
- D'autant plus que la fête de
la Sainte-Anne est importante
et hautement symbolique pour
bien desutochtones.
La dernière visite d'un pape
dans la région de Québec remonte
à 1984 alors que Jean-Paul II
s'était notamment rendu
silique Sainte-Anne.
Le pape François, d'ailleurs,
est déj Québec en 2008
dans le cadre d'un congrès
eucharistique alors qu'il était
encore cardinal.
ce stade préliminaire
du périple, aucune mention des
sites d'anciens pensionnats
de Kamloops, en Colombie-
Britannique, et de Marieval, eùs
de tombes anonymes ont été
retrouvées.
ALAIN PRONKIN, spécialiste
de l'actualité religieuse
- Il doit y aller et il va
sûrement le faire, donc
il s'agit de voir, au niveau
du voyage, qu'est-ce qui va être
le plus... J'allais dire facile
à faire, compte tenu des
déplacements importants.
- Bien que plusieurs évêques
canadiens soient d'accord
avec cette idée, ces dernier
répètent néanmoins que malgré
la volonté du pape, rien n'est
certain quant à son voyage.
Sa sainteté a 85 ans, et la
pandémie n'est pas terminée.
De quoi agacer ceux qui ont vécu
dans les pensionnats
et qui attendent des excuses
depuis des décennies.
MICHÈLE AUDETTE,
sénatrice indépendante
- Les gens sont en train
de mourir, les gens sont
en train de nous q
la plupart des générations
qui ont été affectés par ça.
Alors, je comprends le contexte
de COVID, de pandémie,
mais, à mon avis, l'incertitude,
on n'est plus capables
avec ça, là.
- Si la visite du pape
se concrétise, celle-ci pourrain
des survivants des pensionnats.
Il reste maintenant à voir
dans quelles régions l'Église
voudra se faire pardonner.
Ici Colin Côté-Paulette,
Radio-Canada, à Sainte-Anne-de-
Beaupré.